the jury found you guilty
the judge sentenced you to one of the
most dangerous prisons on earth
and if you're not careful you could
spend the rest of your life behind these
walls
once you're locked up
who can you trust
could you successfully make a break for
it
and what or who would you eat if they
ran out of food
this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
locked up in the most dangerous prison
for 20 years
this is one of the worst prisons in the
world
and now
it's your home
you might spend your days avoiding gangs
and fighting off starvation
and you have nothing but time on your
hands so
how will you spend it
because once that gate closes the rules
of the outside world won't apply to you
anymore
now your fight or flight instinct will
kick in
if you're backed into a corner by the
other inmates
should you fight back
you're about to spend two decades with
some of the most dangerous people who
have ever existed
but if you take things day by day
hey you might leave this place alive
[Music]
as you step inside these prison walls
your heart may begin to race
while this place might seem chaotic it's
nothing compared to what's happening
inside your body
stress will make your body produce
hormones like cortisol
which could decrease your appetite
considering what's on the menu
that's probably for the best
but we'll get back to that
with these chemicals stirring inside you
they could send you into a panic attack
or a fist fight
but be careful with whom you pick a
fight
it wouldn't be some sort of schoolyard
brawl
in prison every relationship you build
or ruin
will have a consequence
[Music]
if you get sentenced to the gitarama
prison in rwanda your fellow inmates
would be war criminals sex offenders and
cannibals
gangs run life inside these walls and if
you want a chance to survive
you'll need someone watching your back
this prison packs inmates in so tightly
that no one can guarantee your safety
and with food supplies so low and no one
looking out for you
some of these criminals have turned into
cannibals
sleep with one eye open because the
inmates in here could eat you alive
[Music]
if you've been in solitary confinement
this whole time
you could be suffering from anxiety and
paranoia
what's that
wait who said that
but if you were in the general prison
population with a gang you might have
established a reputation
in the defunct karen deru penitentiary
in brazil a gang could have helped you
survive riots and malnutrition
hoarding food and medical supplies could
help you avoid starvation and disease
you wouldn't be getting any professional
medical help because
doctors avoid entering this facility at
all costs
with all the violence and death in here
maybe it's time to plan your escape
okay you're halfway through your
sentence and more than ready to leave
this hellscape
but
how are you going to get out you gotta
let me out of here
oh okay remember relationships in
prisons can pay out in different ways
if you've made friends with the guards
and staff
you might earn someone's trust
and getting intimate details about their
lives might give you the leverage you'll
need to escape
whether it's through blackmail or a
romantic encounter
these choices might be your only way out
unless you're ready to start digging and
that might take another six months
after all it took three prisoners six
months to tunnel out of alcatraz in the
united states
and
if you get caught
do you think you could last in this
prison much longer
seriously how long has it been
if you gave up hope of escaping
you could find work in a prison factory
earning around a dollar fifteen an hour
this may not seem like much but this
cash
could pay for food from the commissary
in prisons like california's san quentin
and now you don't have to eat
well
whatever that is
but don't get too laid back in that
sunny prison yard
in san quentin some of the worst serial
killers in history would be your fellow
inmates
hopefully you'll never have to come back
here
of course some circumstances could make
you feel like a prisoner anyway
like what if you were trapped in a
grocery store for the rest of your
life well
grab a cart because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]